so here's a question the Avengers have
had a lot of people as part of their
lineup from their introduction in 1963
until their presumed destruction at the
end of time runs out and so if we had to
pick the top six most powerful Avengers
in the history of their entire lineup
who would they be well in this video
we're going to be answering that
question by counting down the top six
most powerful Avengers in the history of
Marvel Comics and we're going to be
kicking this list off with a number 6
spot with none other than the character
of Deadpool now a lot of people may be
scratching their heads and saying huh
Deadpool was an Avenger when did this
happen
yes Deadpool was an Avenger in fact
death will became an Avenger for the
very first time in the history of
Marvel's continuity with the axis event
when the Red Skull had used the brain of
Charles Xavier to resurrect the powerful
villain onslaught now during this battle
with the onslaught I guess as you
referred to in the axis event red
onslaught what we find is that among the
heroes who have been almost completely
incapacitated are Tony Stark and Tony
Stark head basically had his armor
completely drained of its power source
and so while he was basically in this
helpless position what we found was that
Deadpool had arrived to get Tony Stark
back into the fight but the only way the
Deadpool would do this is if Tony Stark
agreed to make him an Avenger and so
while the axis event left a lot to be
desired while the story wasn't as great
as it could have been I would say that
Deadpool celebration of being inducted
into the ranks of the Avengers by
replacing the lyrics from Smash Mouth
I'm a believer with I'm an Avenger
that's probably the single greatest
moment in the axis event so coming in on
the number 5 spot on our list is
Hyperion now as we've discussed in a
previous video Hyperion is a superhero
from an alternate earth with a history
that follows almost identical to the
history of Superman and DC Comics the
Hyperion was born on a dying world in an
alternate reality where he was sent
basically from that dying world to that
alternate realities version of planet
Earth now there he was raised by a man
named father and who is basically Todd
what it means to be a contributing
member of
Eydie and he actually went on to form a
superhero group or superhero team called
the squadron supreme but when an
incursion that is to say the collision
of two earths
took place in this alternate reality
alongside another reality what we found
was that once these universes collided
and both the universes were destroyed
that Hyperion was the sole survivor and
so Hyperion had basically been plucked
from his alternate reality and brought
into the mainstream Marvel universe
where he eventually became a member of
the Avengers team and even part of the
multiversal Avengers which was a group
that was sent into the multiverse to try
to find a way to stop the encourages
which of course as we know they were
unsuccessful and Hyperion was killed
alongside Thor Odin's son in the battle
with the beyonders now number four on
our list comes in the form of the
Incredible Hulk and I would say there's
really no reason to run over the powers
the Incredible Hulk here we pretty much
know what it is but as a character with
infinite strength The Incredible Hulk
clearly belongs on any list of the most
powerful Avengers in the history of
their lineup but I would say one of the
more powerful one the more impressive
displays of the Incredible Hulk power
actually came during the world war hulk
event when what had happened was that
prior to world war hulk the incredible
hulk had been cast out of the planet
Earth by Reed Richards by Charles Xavier
by Tony Stark by Black Bolt of the
Inhumans and Doctor Strange a group that
basically made up the the name of the
Illuminati and the result was that when
the Incredible Hulk returned back to the
planet Earth during the world war hulk
event he was more pissed off than he had
ever been in the history of his
continuity in fact he was so pissed off
he was so mad then with the strength
being corresponding directly to his
anger that he had stomped on the ground
and the result was that it had shaken
the entire eastern seaboard now this
version of The Incredible Hulk is
referred to as world breaker Hulk and
the reason why was because this version
the Incredible Hulk was so incredibly
powerful that if he wanted to he could
have simply broken the planet Earth and
a half in fact it took a fully powered
Robert Reynolds this century to fight
the Incredible Hulk to a dead standstill
and the two of them actually reverted
back to their normal human forms in
order to get the Incredible Hulk to stop
the Incredible Hulk wasn't really
defeated he wasn't knocked out he
basically just fought to the point of
exhaustion and that I think is probably
one of the most incredible feats in the
history of any superhero to go against
the incredible hope but it gives us an
idea of just how powerful he is now
number three on our list comes in the
form of Kevin Connor
now Kevin Connor is a superhero known as
the star brand and with this character
what we're going to start doing here is
we're going to start moving away from
the run-of-the-mill superheroes that is
to say superheroes who have power like I
guess super-strength who have healing
factors who have energy projection
things like that and we're going to
start getting into the territory of
stupidly powerful characters of
characters who are so ridiculously
overpowered that it makes you wonder why
in god's name are they even in existence
in the counter books let alone on the
Avengers team star brand represents what
is basically the next stage of human
evolution he's more or less of a
protector of humanity as it's supposed
to evolve into the next stage of its
evolution but as we know because of the
multiversal collapse this is not going
to happen because star bland is
basically a protector of humanity and
whatever its next stage of evolution may
be the power of star brand isn't
necessarily split up into things like
super strength and so on it's simply
that he has enough power to fight any
foe regardless of how powerful that foe
may be now these are characters who were
confined largely to the people that
we've seen him face so far so we have no
real idea what the upper limits of his
powers are but basically what Marvel
tells us here were star brand is that he
has infinite power that there's no limit
to how much energy he can put off at any
given point in time what what we end up
finding here is that with the collapse
of the multiverse and the Battle of the
beyonders towards the end of time runs
out and the start of secret wars that
star brand actually is alongside Thor
Odinson and Hyperion during the battle
with the beyonders and sacrifices his
life by letting off all of his energy
went ah at one time then an effort to
defeat the beyonders and so the result
is that star brand is now gone from the
Marvel landscape
he's now totally eliminated from that
landscape entirely and we may or may not
ever see any version of him again now
coming in at number 2 on our list is dr.
Steven strange now as a sorcerer supreme
of the mainstream Marvel Universe there
are very few things that dr. strange
can't do by employing various magical
artifact
dr. strange is capable of the following
feats are here the following things that
he's capable of doing he's capable of
energy projection of astral projection
that is to say his spirit or his mind
leaving his body and traveling to
another plane of existence he's capable
of energy manipulation he has cosmic
awareness he can manipulate portals to
other dimensions and even manipulate
those dimensions itself
he has pyrokinesis where he can
basically control or manipulate fire he
has a power of flight he can make force
fields he has an enhanced healing factor
he can hypnotize people he can cast
illusions in the minds of other people
to make them see think feel or hear
anything that he wants he has the power
of invisibility he has a power of
immortality he has the power of
necromancy that is to say the ability to
bring people back from the dead he can
phase through solid matter he can take
possession of other people he has the
power of telekinesis telepathy
teleportation and time-travel Jesus this
guy can do everything there's really no
limit to what it is that he can do he is
a vastly powerful character and so the
question becomes this if dr. strange can
do all these things then what Avenger
could possibly be more powerful than him
the most powerful Avenger in the history
of Marvel's continuity is squirrel I'm
just messing about its Scarlet Witch
Scarlet Witch is the most powerful
Avenger in the history of Marvel Comics
The Scarlet Witch can do pretty much
everything Doctor Strange can do here
but the difference is that she also has
the ability to warp reality and this is
really what made her powerful now we
don't know if dr. strange doesn't or
does have the ability to work reality it
may be that he does and he's never used
that power before but the fact remains
that the Scarlet Witch had basically
worked reality in his entirety during
the house of MFN where she had basically
switched things in a way where the
magneto and her family I guess the
family of magneto were the head of all
mutant society with humans being under
mutants in this new world this was a
whole new universe not only that not
only was this reality changed
we actually find out later on that when
the Scarlet Witch had work reality and
set everything back and she had stripped
all the mutants of their powers that it
was a multiversal effect that other
realities and other realities in the
Marvel multiverse that mutants had lost
their powers there too because of the
actions of the Scarlet Witch and so and
that I would say makes her the most
powerful Avenger in the history of the
Avengers team web being said give me
your top six tell me what your top six
most powerful member of the Avengers are
because I'm really really excited to see
what you guys come up with but that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace